we begin the eight o'clock hour with
just with the justice department which
is suing texas over its new law banning
abortions after about six weeks now the
measure effectively prohibits nearly all
abortions there and is the latest
challenge to the 1973 supreme court
decision roe v wade now in a new book
the family row an american story the
daughters of the woman known as jane
rowe talk about their mother for the
very first time melissa mills the oldest
daughter of jane rowe whose real name is
norma mccorvey spoke to r jan crawford
they talked about how the new law is
threatening her mother's legacy
have you followed the law in texas
what are your thoughts on that that's
what i just think it's terrible i think
it's terrible at six weeks you don't
even know you're pregnant most women
don't know until they're eight weeks or
longer further along we're going
backwards we're not going forwards i
mean we've had all these strides like
gay marriages
marijuana being
you know
legalized now we're going back to
a woman has no choice of her own body
the author of the family road joshua
prager is the first person to find and
bring all three of norma mccorvey's
daughters together he joins us for his
first interview about the new book josh
good morning to you good morning number
one let me just say it's a very book
very big book you've devoted 10 years of
your life to the research about that
we'll talk about why it was so important
to you but i didn't know and i was glad
to find out that a lot of people didn't
know that baby roe
is still alive
yeah i think with this case you just
assumed that she had been aborted did
you know that i did not know that i had
assumed i think like many of us that the
woman who had brought about the legal
right to abortion had an abortion
herself
but then i saw a mention in an article
that she'd actually had a child and i
said to myself wow i read that in 2010
you mentioned it took me a long time
that woman would have poor man i didn't
know but at that point been 40 years old
and i said to myself if he or she knows
who she is then that's probably a big
burden to carry you right that abortion
is very complicated that whenever you
write you're you're sort of declaring
sides or choosing sides but you wanted
to make a point to humanize all of the
people in this story because norma
mccorvey i have to say was tough she was
very loose with the truth yep and i
think that's being kind
um and she had three daughters from
three different men and didn't raise any
of them that's right she gave all three
of her children up to adoption the first
one was actually raised by her own
mother
the other two were given up for adoption
to family she didn't know
and
i said to myself you know it's such a
complicated issue we have a lot of
propaganda there's a lot of rhetoric if
i can humanize this issue if i can sort
of enable people to look at abortion not
through politics but people that that
will help us to sort of get to the heart
of the matter because abortion is
fraught for good reason and that's
really what i tried to do in my book
share something of an expert in secrets
you've done multiple books and reporting
on covering things
it took a lot of work to find shelly
thornton who is the roe baby she spoke
to you and is now public for the first
time where does she stand on this law
that bears her name
i think one of the things that's hard
for her when she was 18 years old that's
when she found out who she was
a tabloid sort of approached her and
said we're going to go forward whether
you want to or not and they were
pressing her pro-life pro-choice
pro-life pro-choice and she it was the
first time she was sort of forced to
think about it well why does a person
have to choose sides in the end what she
said was and she was very much sort of
in the middle i would say her life sort
of resisted the sort of
pat you know um
pro-life pro-choice these categories
that we can assign people in the end she
said that she herself didn't feel
comfortable having an abortion and yet
she believed that um a woman should have
the legal right to choose pro-choice in
the end and i shouldn't say law i should
say supreme court ruling that's exactly
right people are going to read this book
i think millions of people are going to
read this book it's a fantastic
achievement one of the ways they're
going to read it is for ammunition in
what is essentially a 40-year culture
war that's right pro-abortion
pro-abortion rights
uh
who has more ammo you know i i would say
this book is is somewhat unique in terms
of books about row and abortion because
there really is
information that both sides can be very
happy with for example we mentioned the
row baby she had always been a symbol we
didn't know who she was but now the
pro-life can point aha this person
exists had roe not been had abortion um
been legal when norma brought her case
this person this human being would not
be alive that's something they would
like to point to they will point as well
let's say to sarah weddington the lawyer
who argued the case in front of the
supreme court when she was just 26 and i
and i reveal um how she didn't treat
norma properly amongst many other things
she didn't do right she didn't treat her
who co-counsel properly that's something
that they will sort of delight in on the
other side
you know when i didn't set about trying
to sort of ammunition i tried to write
the truth but on the other side the
pro-choice will say hey the pro-life are
always saying you know a woman should
give up her child she should not have an
abortion she should give up her child so
that child can be placed for adoption
well i show in the book that actually
adoption is a very difficult thing for
women who give their children up whereas
actually the overwhelming majority of
women who have an abortion they report
feeling relief not regret which is the
opposite of what the pro-life wish to
say yeah in this book you
you write on the incompatibility of uh
sex and religion but in america these
two things are inextricably intertwined
yeah um do you ever feel like there will
be some uniformity when it comes to
these two things you know that that's a
great question um the thing that
was very helpful to me in writing this
book i wanted to be able to write about
america at large about abortion america
through human beings and norma and her
family they were sort of riven and
pulled apart by the very same things sex
and religion that i feel have pulled
this country apart and
it didn't have to be that way sex and
religion are not by nature incompatible
but they've come to be in this country
do i think at this point that those two
things will suddenly be you know bridged
and people will look at it differently i
unfortunately don't
um i think there's too much that's
happened it's become so politicized
but i do think that if people can look
at these stories and see what happened
not only to norma but her mother and her
grandmother other people who felt that
those two things were incompatible i
think that putting a human face on this
will enable people to better understand
both sides of the divide and let's talk
about the human face of shelly
whose baby wrote she never met her
mother their relationship was very
complicated yeah she talked to her but
she never met her why
so
when they've learned about each other in
1989
um
shelley understandably was not happy
norma had sought her out so that they
could have sort of a very public reunion
she thought it'd be good they could
travel they could perhaps earn money
together they had a very difficult phone
call did they did they did norma called
her they ended up having sort of a
falling out on the phone and norma
actually said to her that you need to
thank me and shelly said why and she
said for not aborting you which is a
horrible thing to say obviously norma
had wanted to do just that but at that
point shelley said we called it quits i
knew i'd never be able to have
relationships and briefly could you talk
about the timing of the book you've been
writing about it as you're researching
but now it's coming out at the same time
that texas is is considering this yeah
it's a very bizarre thing i started as a
rovi wade is in trouble isn't it it's in
a lot of trouble you know the people are
focused right now on the law in texas
but the bigger threat to roe is what's
is what's the supreme court is hearing a
case called dobbs out of jackson
mississippi um that case goes right to
the heart of of roe which is the sort of
viability threshold the fact that
abortion ought to be legal right up to
viability the supreme court can overturn
that um and people are focused right on
texas if it is overturned and and if roe
goes back to the states abortion will be
illegal in in almost half of them um you
wanted to show the humanity on both
sides of the verses and roe v wade
you've you've done that it's a fantastic
achievement thank you very much it
really is appreciated it was a lot of
because it's very complicated it's a lot
of years of your life and it's a lot of
hard work it is
very good job well i appreciate it very
much
aren't you glad you came this morning
i'm very glad we're glad you good luck
on the tour thank you thank you very
much very much the family row is the
name of josh prager's book the family
row and american story to be correct it
goes on sale tomorrow wherever you like
to buy your books